what's it feel like to lose
like we talked about bluffing when it
worked out what about when you
when you go broke
so like in a game i i'm you know
unfortunately i've never gone broke uh
you mean okay full life for life
um i know plenty of people who have um
uh
and i don't think eagle would mind me
saying he went you know he went broke
once in pokeball you know early on when
we were together i feel like you haven't
lived unless you've gone broke oh yeah i
i in some sense right well i i i mean
i'm happy i i've sort of lived through
it vicariously through him when he did
it at the time
but yeah what's it like to lose well it
depends so it depends on the amount it
depends what percentage of your net
worth you've just lost
um
it depends on your brain chemistry it
really you know varies from perspective
you have a very cold calculating way of
thinking about this uh so it depends
what percentage
but it really does right yes
but that's i mean
that's another thing poker trains you to
do you see you you see everything in
percentages um or you see everything in
like roi or expected hourlies or cost
benefit etc you know so
um
that's i i one of the things i've tried
to do is calibrate the strength of my
emotional response to the to the win or
loss that i've
received
because it's it's no good if you like
you know you have a huge emotional
dramatic response to a tiny loss um or
on the flip side you have a huge win and
you're so dead inside that you don't
even feel it well that's you know that's
a shame i want my emotions to calibrate
with reality as much as possible
um
so yeah what's it like to lose i mean
i've had times where i've
lost you know busted out of a tournament
i thought i was going to win in is you
know especially if i got really unlucky
or um or i make a dumb play uh where
i've gone away and like you know kicked
kicked the wall punched a wall i like
nearly broke my hand one time like um
i'm a lot less competitive than i used
to be like i was like pathologically
competitive in my like
late teens early 20s i just had to win
everything um and i think that's sort of
slowly waned as i've gotten older
according to you yeah according to me i
i don't know if others would say the
same right um i feel like ultra
competitive people
like i've heard joe rogan say this to me
it's like i think he's a lot less
competitive than he used to be i don't
know about that
oh i believe it no i totally believe it
like
because as you get you can still be like
i care about winning like when you know
i play a game with my buddies online or
you know whatever it is polytopia is my
current obsession like
thank you for passing on your obsession
to me are you playing now yeah i'm
playing now we gotta have a game but i'm
terrible and i enjoy playing terribly i
don't want to have a game because that's
gonna pull me into your monster of of
like uh competitive play it's important
i'm enjoying playing on the
i can't
you just do that you just do the points
thing you know against the bots yeah
against the bots and i can't even do the
uh
there's like a hard one and there's a
very that's crazy yeah that's crazy i
can't i don't even enjoy the hard one
the crazy i really don't enjoy because
it's intense you have to constantly try
to win as opposed to enjoy building a
little world and
yeah no no there's no time for
exploration in polytechnic you've got to
them well when once you graduate from
the crazies then you can come play the
the graduate from the crazy yeah so in
order to be able to play a decent game
against like you know our group um
you'll need to be
you'll need to be consistently winning
like 90 of games against 15 crazy bots
yeah and you'll be able to like it
there'll be i could i could teach you it
within a day honestly um how to be the
craziest how to beat the crazies and
then and then you'll be ready for the
big leagues generalizes uh to more than
just polytopia but okay uh why were we
talking about polytopia losing hurts
losing hers oh yeah yes competitiveness
over time um oh yeah
i think it's more that at least for me
i still care about playing about winning
when i choose to play something it's
just that i don't see the world as
zero-sum as i used to be you know
um i think as you one gets older and
wiser
you start to see the world more as a
positive something or at least you're
more aware of externalities
of of scenarios of competitive
interactions
um and so
yeah i just like i'm more and i'm more
aware of my own you know like
if i have a really strong emotional
response to losing and that makes me
then feel shitty for the rest of the day
and then i beat myself up mentally for
it like i'm now more aware that that
that's unnecessary negative externality
so i'm like okay i need to find a way to
turn this down you know dial this down a
bit was poker the thing that has
if you think back at your life
and think about some of the lower points
of your life like the darker places
you've gone in your mind did it have to
do something with poker
like what did losing spark the
um the descent into darkness or was it
something else um
i think my darkest points in poker were
when
i was wanting to quit and move on to
other things
but i felt like i hadn't
ticked all the boxes i wanted to tick
yeah like i wanted to be the most
winningest
female player which is by itself a bad
goal um you know that was one of my
initial goals and i was like well i
haven't you know and i wanted to win a
wpt event i've won one of these i won
one of these but i want one of those as
well and
that
sort of again like it's a drive of like
over optimization to random metrics that
i decided were important
um without much wisdom at the time but
then like carried on um
that made me continue chasing it longer
than i still actually had the passion to
chase it for and i don't i don't have
any regrets that you know i played for
as long as i did because who knows you
know
i wouldn't be sitting here i wouldn't be
living this incredible life that i'm
living now um this is this is the height
of your life right now this is it peak
experience
absolute pinnacle
here in
no it is i mean i i wouldn't change a
thing about my life right now and i feel
very blessed to say that um
so but
the dark times were in sort of like 2016
to 18 even sooner really where i was
like
i stopped loving the game
and i was going through the motions
and
i would
that and and then i was like you know i
would take the losses harder than i
needed to yeah because i'm like oh it's
another one and it was i was aware that
like i felt like my life was ticking
away and i was like is this gonna be
what's on my tombstone oh yeah she
played the game of you know this
zero-sum game of poker slightly more
optimally than her next opponent
like cool great legacy you know so
i just wanted you know there was
something in me that knew i needed to be
doing something
more
directly impactful um and just
meaningful it was like a search for
meaning and i think it's a thing a lot
of poker players even a lot of i imagine
any
games players who
sort of
love intellectual pursuits
um
you know i think you should ask magnus
carlsen this question yeah walking away
from chess right yeah like it must be so
hard for him you know he's been on the
top for so long
and it's like well now what he's got
this incredible brain like
what to put it to
um
and
yeah it's it's this weird uh moment
where i just spoken with people that won
multiple gold medals at the olympics
and the depression hits hard after you
win
doesn't mean crash
because it's a kind of a goodbye saying
goodbye to that person to all the dreams
you had the thought
you thought would give meaning to your
life but in fact
life is full of constant pursuits of
meaning it doesn't you don't like arrive
and figure it all out and there's
endless bliss knowledge it continues
going on and on you constantly have to
figure out
to rediscover yourself and so for you
like that struggle to say goodbye to
poker you have to like find the next
there's always a bigger game that's the
thing that's my like motto is like
what's the next game and
more importantly
because obviously game usually implies
zero sum like what
what's the game which is like omni win
look what you win omni when when is omni
because
if everyone plays zero-sum games that's
a fast track to either completely
stagnate as a civilization but more
actually far more likely to extinct
ourselves
um you know like the playing field is
finite
yeah
you know nuclear powers are playing uh
you know a game of poker with uh with
you know but their chips are nuclear
weapons right
and
the stakes have gotten so large that if
anyone makes a single bet you know fires
some weapons the the playing field
breaks i made a video on this like
you know the the fight the the playing
field is finite and if we keep playing
these adversarial
zero-sum games uh thinking that we you
know
in order for us to win someone else has
to lose or if we lose that you know
someone else wins that that will extinct
us
it's just a matter of when
you